una nueva propuesta de la Unión Europea
para reducir el desperdicio de plástico
la comisión europea propuso normas más
estrictas para la reducción de uso de
envases y limitar el uso de materiales
para los empaques de entregas en línea
Todo bajo el gran objetivo de ser
emisiones netas para 2025 Pues esta meta
estaría en riesgo si no se toman medidas
contra la contaminación que a su vez
aumentan las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero
la forma en la que se empaquen los
productos puede y debe hacerse mucho
mejor Creo que todo el mundo lo ha
experimentado y es algo en línea y
vienen una caja enorme que está a medio
vacía o contiene capas dobles para que
el producto parezca más grande de lo que
es o vas a una cafetería Y en lugar de
que te sirvan en platos normales te dan
comida y envases de un solo uso el
exceso de embalaje es una molestia para
nosotros y cada vez más dañino para
nuestro medio ambiente
con la propuesta el bloque comunitario
Espera que para 2030 la reducción de
residuos de envases per cápita sea de un
5% y que llegue al 15% para 2040 En
comparación con los niveles de 2018
ciertos envases de plástico como bolsas
de té cápsulas de café bolsas de
plástico ligeras y etiquetas adhesivas
deberán ser compostables
nuestra propuesta tiene como objetivo
tres cosas primero reducimos el empaque
donde es necesario en segundo lugar
queremos que hayan más empaques
reutilizables por ejemplo para 2040 la
mayoría de cafés para llevar vendrán en
una taza reutilizable o haremos que cada
uno traiga su tasa y tercero todos los
vasos deben ser fáciles de reciclar o
que estén hechos de material reciclado
el proyecto necesita la aprobación del
parlamento europeo y los gobiernos de la
Unión Europea para convertirse en ley